[Música]
ah
la cepa es originaria de manaus capital
del estado de amazonas donde actualmente
está causando estragos según los
especialistas el variante no causan
casos más graves pero es más contagiosa
incluso entre la población más joven
ahora desbordados los hospitales de
amazonas han trasladado un poco menos de
500 pacientes a los hospitales de otros
estados según el ex ministro de salud
luis enrique mande está en poco menos de
dos meses brasil puede tener una mega
epidemia causado por la nueva variante
del boro navieros detectada a principios
de enero la mutación brasileña del virus
en el 90% de los casos detectados en el
amazonas todavía en estudio se sabe que
esta mutación tiene similitud con las
identificadas en el reino unido y
sudáfrica
a
una de las principales variantes del
cobi 19 ha sido la 501 v2 identifica
identificada originalmente acá en
sudáfrica según las investigaciones esta
variante el virus no es necesariamente
más letal pero sí tiene una tasa de
infección mucho más alta las
investigaciones también están tratando
de determinar qué tan resistente es esta
nueva variante a las vacunas ya
desarrolladas esta variante que una
carga viral más alta y se desarrollan
mutaciones en las proteínas que son la
parte del virus que se adhieren a las
células humanas
por otra parte sudáfrica ha sido
criticada por la tardanza en
proporcionar las vacunas a la población
y sobre esta semana llegaron un millón
de dosis de la vacuna astrazéneca
provenientes del serum institute de la
india se priorizarán a los trabajadores
de la salud para que reciban este millón
de dosis y se espera que a lo largo del
mes lleguen otras 500 mil dosis
adicionales del serum institute
[Música]
en california científicos aseguran haber
descubierto dos variantes del hobbit y
es que también aseguran no saber si
estas nuevas variantes son más
contagiosas o si son más peligrosas para
los seres humanos que el virus normal
del cob y ahora mismo hay más de mil
pacientes afectados con estas dos
variantes que además son exclusivas del
estado de california según los
científicos estas dos variantes han
crecido un 25% desde que fueron
descubiertas a principios del mes de
diciembre ahora mismo además también
preocupa que no hay un plan organizado
de vacunación masiva todavía no se sabe
exactamente cuándo ni cómo se va a
llevar a cabo ni en qué centros en san
francisco tan solo se han abierto dos
centros por ahora además tampoco ayuda
que justo la semana pasada se volvieron
a reabrir muchos de los locales y
restaurantes que habían estado cerrados
más de un mes y medio
[Música]